[MUSIC PLAYING]
FLORIAN GSCHWANDTNER:
I grew up on a farm.
It was a very cool
childhood, because you're
growing up next to your
dad, working on the fields.
One thing what I really
learned is, what does work
all day long actually mean?
This is where, for
me, my heart to become
an entrepeneur somehow started.
Just a few years ago,
me and my co-founders
started almost with nothing.
Now having more than 200
employees and more than 220
million downloads.
And being part of Adidas,
this is incredible.
NINETTE GIARDINA: I was 40 years
old when I started running,
and it all started
with a challenge.
I signed up Alexis, my
daughter, for a 10k.
And I decided to
sign up for a 5k
to show her that I support
her, and that she's not going
to be the only one running.
Alexis didn't think
that I can do it.
She said, like you're going to
get off the couch and run a 5k.
She told me to use Runtastic,
and I took the challenge,
and I ran the whole 5k.
Since I've started running, I've
been doing all kinds of races.
I am currently training
for my second marathon.
What running has taught me is
that I can achieve so much.
BRETT KOPF: I was
diagnosed with a bunch
of learning
disabilities, and I spent
two years struggling in school.
I had this teacher
named Ms. Whitefield
who totally changed my life.
Hey, Ms. Whitefield!
The whole ethos of Remind
was built around the thought
that if we could help give the
Ms. Whitefields of the world
superpowers and make
them more efficient,
it could have an enormous
impact on the education system.
So I would spend
my time speaking
to hundreds of teachers
across the country
while my brother was locked in
a room learning how to code.
Today, Remind has over 23
million active teachers,
students, and
parents in over 90%
of US K-12 school districts.
We would have never been
able to reach those customers
if Google Play did not exist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TINA LEMIRE: One of
my students, Jason--
he struggled, especially with
turning things in on time.
One day, he came to me--
JASON MURRAY: And then
I was like, I bet you
that if I do all my
work and pass the test,
you'll throw us a party.
I kept receiving
messages from Ms. Lemire
and my other classmates to
help me and motivate me.
TINA LEMIRE: As
a result, I lost.
They got to have
an ice cream party.
It was probably some
of the best work
that I've ever seen him produce.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRANSHU PATNI: Over
30 million users
are currently using the app.
We're bigger than any
university or school that
has existed for ages in India.
What inspires us as a
team and what motivates us
the most is when
we hear users talk
about how learning
English with the app
has impacted them in
such a positive way.
That truly empowers
us to keep going
and to make a bigger impact.
SIDIQUE MALIK: When I
retired from my job,
I decided to do
something useful.
That's why I joined
Hello English.
I believe that there are
so many kids around us--
they want to learn English.
Joining Hello English
gave me enough confidence
to go to my hometown and
teach the poor and needy.
Hello, children.
How are you?
What is your name?
SPEAKER 1: I'm [INAUDIBLE].
SIDIQUE MALIK: Very good.
SPEAKER 2: My name
is [INAUDIBLE]..
SIDIQUE MALIK: [INAUDIBLE].
English is for higher education.
The key for a better life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ODED BEN DOV: I started
Sesame about five years ago.
At the time, I was
doing computer vision
and gesture technology.
And I got on TV to
demonstrate a game
I developed that was
controlled using head gestures.
And I got a phone
call the next day,
and the guy said, hi, I can't
can move my hands or legs.
Can you make me a
smartphone I could use?
GIORA LIVNE: He
came, looked at me,
and said, well, I
have a new company.
I told him that this
will be much better
to do good for the whole world.
And he was convinced.
ODED BEN DOV: It really
put a new perspective
on what technology
can accomplish
and how it can change lives.
And the Android operating
system's open nature
really allowed me to
innovate beyond what
I could imagine at first.
Every successful user
is not just a number.
It's a whole life.
It's a whole story.
And we take those with us,
and those propel us forward
to keep doing what we do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]